there are several other Republicans who
are not happy with Kevin McCarthy we've
got a compilation here this is from CNN
uh we'll start with Republican Dan
Bishop then there's some from Chip Roy
and some other people take a look
how much I mean how much confidence do
you have in the speaker right now none
zero
what basis is there for confidence you
cannot forfeit the tool of Republican
Unity it was not necessary to do with
the speaker lying about the way he's
characterizing this Bill yes he's flying
but the bill is chock full of things
that are that are cosmetic and
artificial that have the same exact
effect mccarth has lost some trust in
how this has been handled what I said
was we got to re-look at how our
leadership structure is in place
something like that on Glenn show
because we can't do what we're doing
right now
um we were being very successful for
five months this was a mistake we
abandoned the structure that was making
us successful so we're gonna have to
rethink it all what was emphatically
clear in all of our conversations in
January was that we would be reporting
things out of the rules committee
unanimously and right now that is in
jeopardy
okay so these guys have some leverage
because of the concessions that they got
out of McCarthy those five months ago
the question here really is what is
McCarthy's game is he just kind of going
all in on the swamp was this really the
best deal that he could do is he
thinking about it see one of the
problems here is that no you know this
because of the way the mainstream media
is in bed with the Democrats no matter
what happens Republicans get blamed and
I sense that that probably is what
McCarthy fears he fears okay if we don't
increase the debt ceiling let's say we
do what we think is right we completely
are not going to vote for this America
goes into default it potentially leads
us to a recession right like that's
that's just reality
his feeling is oh I suspect his feeling
I can't speak for him but I suspect his
private feeling would be oh we would
have done the right thing not given the
Democrats what they want we'd have a
temporary pain point with the recession
but the people will all blame us because
of the the coordination between the
Democrats and the mainstream media the
people all they must and then when we're
in a recession and P and you know gas
prices are up again and the supply chain
is struggling again and groceries cost
more everyone will blame us and that
will be bad for us in the long term so I
think he's playing more of a political
game which is part of the problem of
politics it's always about politics
that's a bit of a problem and the guys
who were standing up against him they're
playing I think what what I would say is
a little bit more of a principled game
and it's for all of you to decide like
which side of that you want to fall on
[Music]